en el vídeo anterior dimos una visión
general de las reacciones dependientes
de la luz que ocurren fundamentalmente
dentro o a través de la membrana ty la
coidh al que hicimos un acercamiento a
una membrana ty la cuidad y vimos que
tenemos energía luminosa o energía
lumínica que excita a los electrones
dentro de este par de clorofila
de 680 y ese electrón energizado es
transferido de una molécula a otra y
conforme hace eso va a ir a estados de
energía cada vez más bajos y una parte
de esa energía liberada se utiliza para
transferir protones de hidrógeno a
través de la membrana y luego finalmente
ese electrón llegará al fotosistema 1
donde es excitado de nuevo si pensamos
en él como el mismo electrón no
necesariamente tiene que ser exactamente
el mismo electrón pero podemos pensar
que ese mismo electrón está siendo
excitado de nuevo por la energía
luminosa y luego puede ir a estados de
energía cada vez más
y esta vez va a ser utilizado para
reducir ndp más a enea de ph el enea de
ph es una molécula necesaria para el
ciclo de calvin y el atp es otra
molécula que necesitamos para el ciclo
de calvin y la forma en que producimos
atp es mediante la concentración de
iones de hidrógeno que aumenta en el
interior debido a que los iones son
bombeados a través de la membrana y
debido a los iones de hidrógeno
sobrantes del agua después de que ésta
ha sido despojada de sus electrones para
reemplazar ese electrón excitado que
originalmente se encontraba en el par de
clorofila
p 680 la creciente concentración de
iones de hidrógeno puede ser utilizada
para activar la atp sin tasa que crea
atp a partir de adp y un grupo fosfato y
vimos lo mismo por aquí sin ver los
diferentes componentes tenemos luz que
excita al electrón el electrón va a
estados de energía cada vez más
y conforme haces o pádel fotosistema 2
al photo sistema 1 y una parte de esa
energía se está utilizando para bombear
iones de hidrógeno dentro del lumen y la
coidh al luego s electrone puede
excitarse de nuevo y conforme es
transferido va a estados de energía cada
vez menores y esa energía puede ser
utilizada para producir enea de pe h
donde una vez más sus electrones se
encuentran todavía en un estado de alta
energía por lo que es un agente reductor
fuerte y debido a eso es muy valioso en
el ciclo de calvin esa energía que viene
de actuar como un agente reductor fuerte
puede ser utilizada para ayudar en la
creación del azúcar y nuevamente una vez
que el par de clorofila 1.680 ha donado
un electrón como es reemplazado ese
electrón pues se lo quita al agua
lo que tengo aquí es un diagrama más
detallado que etiqueta a algunos de los
actores y lo importante aquí es la idea
conceptual de lo que está pasando en las
reacciones dependientes de la luz lo que
ya vimos y cubrimos con más detalle en
el vídeo anterior pero muchas veces en
tu clase de biología o en tu libro de
biología verás que se habla de cosas
como el complejo citocromo y plas toki
nona y cosas por el estilo así que
quisiera que viéramos todo esto para que
no te sientas intimidado cuando lo veas
y que veas que se trata de los actores
de los que hemos estado hablando esta
imagen fue tomada y modificada de las
reacciones dependientes de la luz en la
fotosíntesis figura 8 de openstack es
college biología así que por aquí
tenemos al foto sistema 2 y vemos a la
luz que por la forma en que está
representado aquí no está interactuando
directamente con el par de clorofila ape
680 dentro del foto sistema 2
que actúa sobre algunas de estas
moléculas vecinas y conforme sus
electrones se excitan y luego van a
niveles de energía más bajos la energía
puede ser utilizada para excitar a los
electrones vecinos esto continúa
sucediendo y esa energía se transfiere
finalmente para excitar al electrón en
ese par de 680 y entonces ese electrón
es transferido al primer sector de
electrones puedes ver esto en tus libros
de texto de biología es transferido a la
fe oficina que puede transferir el
electrón al aplasto quignón a que está
interactuando en este complejo citocromo
que transfiere el electrón del aplastó
aquí no nada al aplasto cia ni na y
conforme hace esto puedes ver a los
genes hidrógenos que se transfieren
desde el exterior de ntt y la coidh al
interior del tila coi de que es
exactamente lo que hemos estado hablando
y a medida que avanzamos al fotosistema
1s electrón puede ser transferido del
aplasto yanina al par de clorofila p 700
y vuelve a ser excitado y una vez más la
luz no necesariamente lo excita de
manera directa puede excitar otras
moléculas dentro del foto sistema 1 pero
la energía finalmente se transfiere a la
clorofila excita su electrón y luego se
pasa de una molécula a otra va a la
férrea toxina que está siendo utilizada
en conjunción es uno de los sectores que
la enzima ndp más reductasa necesita
junto con el ndp más por lo que
esencialmente está reduciendo ndp más
junto con este electrón que está en la
férrea toxina para producir enea de ph
y una vez más qué está pasando aquí pues
esta es la atp sin tasa que está
utilizando todo este aumento en la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno en
el interior del tila koide para bombear
o para alimentar el motor o podríamos
decir que la atp zinc azsa es el motor
que es accionado conforme estos iones de
hidrógeno van a favor de su gradiente de
concentración y esa energía se utiliza
para enlazar un grupo fosfato con el atp
para producir atp así que esencialmente
he dicho lo mismo dos o tres veces en
los últimos dos o tres vídeos pero lo
hice porque la primera vez que vemos
esto nos parece muy muy intimidante y
muy muy complejo y en realidad es algo
bastante complejo y francamente es
increíble que este tipo de cosas estén
sucediendo en la planta que estoy viendo
por mi ventana en este momento me parece
impresionante que esto esté ocurriendo
en la naturaleza y hay partes de esto
que aún no se entienden completamente y
necesitan
descubiertas pero al mismo tiempo la
idea general no es tan intimidante como
lo pueden hacer parecer estos diagramas
así que espero que encuentres esto
inspirador a mí así me lo parece y no
tan intimidante como algunas de estas
palabras te pueden hacer sentir en un
principio